لا هدنه تصمد ولا عيد يشفع فاللغه الخصوم
تحتد اكثر ويكثر الرصاص يسمع صداه هنا
يسقط مدنيون ويتداعى قطع باكمله قتلى
وجرحى بالعشرات اكثر من 600 قتيل ومئات
الجرح بحسب وزاره الصحه السودانيه اعداد
تضغط على قطاع طبي على وشك الانهيار
خروج متواليه لعدد من المستشفيات خارج
الخدمه وايضا هنالك عدد من المنتجات
الاخرى ايضا هي على حافه الاغلاق وزاره
الصحه السودانيه قالت
مستشفيات تعمل بكامل طاقتها في الخرطوم
وبينت ان عشره مستشفيات حكوميه خرجت عن
الخدمه في العاصمه نقابه الاطباء قالت ان
14 مستشفى تعرضت للقصف في البلاد بينما
يعملون نحو 23 مستشفى بشكل جزئي لكنها
مهدده بالاغلاق
[موسيقى]
الطبيه
وفي ظل ظروف صعبه تعمل منظمات دوليه
واماميه لدعم القطاع الطبي المنهك لكن
القتال يعقد اي مسعا لذلك منظمه اطباء بلا
حدود قالت ان فريقها الطبي لم يتمكن من
ادخال امدادات طبيه اضافيه الى السودان
المنظمه اشارت الى ان الامدادات في مستشفى
الفاشر مثلا تكفي لثلاثه اسابيع فقط
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات